I was like you wear your black leather
we like yeah we good we New York I you
know what I actually it's a solid choice
I was like look more like New York and
El thank you for
noticing have you all met before well
backstage backstage so awesome this is
way back there uh like 10 ft it's like
this is the best part of doing this show
is that every time I'm on I like get to
meet someone I'm kind of fangirling over
me to it's so cool and last time I think
it was it was Dr Phil like we became
friends after sitting on the couch and
he invited me on his podcast so I'm
excited to do your podcast I want to
start one just so you can be thank you
for the invite prier episode it's
awesome you sounded so good my God
you're very nice wait well speaking of
Music this is insane and I love you for
this I heard that you spent 25 Grand on
Taylor Swift tickets okay yes I did I
just want to say that it was a conscious
decision because
I I okay I make them better well okay I
went to I've been to nine era's tour
shows this year like when I'm not on
tour I just like go to her tour it just
like fills my life up with so much joy
I'm in my late 30s I'm in my latest 30
and I just feel like I don't have kids
and I kind of did the math and I'm like
if I had kids I'd be paying for like
dance camp and swim lessons kids are
expensive I suggest use all this money
and I was going to freeze my eggs in
January and that's like about how much
it costs and then I just decided um not
to freeze them I decided to burn them
so it's a new thing they're offering
it's really so you saved a lot of money
yeah so exactly so I was like you know
what I'm going to take that chunk of
money that I was going to use to do that
and I'm just going to like have a really
fun summer so I went Buck Wild yeah yeah
and it was so fun I I yeah that's me
just um gazing at her disturbing her I
mean and I like disturbing her I feel
like it's distracting I don't know I
want to ask you guys like when you're
performing and there's someone in the
front row because at comedy shows people
just sit down no one's like screaming my
you know your name and like so I don't
know what the perspective is so I'm
front row and I'm taking video of her I
have her phone case cuz I buy everything
she owns there's like a account I follow
that tells you tells you what clothes
she has security somewhere right now is
like
Nikki it's all the stuff she owns under
a certain price point I buy but I have
her phone case and I remember at one
point I was filming her and I could see
her kind of look and go like is that my
phone like you know when you see your
own phone case phone is it like do you
blur your eyes like is it distracting
when people are singing and like maybe
they're singing The Wrong lyric does it
ever like mess you up well usually I'm
the one singing The Wrong
lyrics yeah does it distract you no I
mean you know there's always somebody
crazy in the front of I like that person
you you make me happy the girl I've been
told I'm the most enthusiastic like
person in the front you get hecklers I
feel like we don't get hecklers in that
sense so comedy gets heckers um so wait
season three of f boy what's going on
other than it's it's F boy island is an
insane show that I host it's a reality
dating show that is you know a bunch of
guys that show up there three girls
looking for love and then there's a
bunch of guys and half of them are there
for the money and to Li it's ridiculous
it's awesome thank you for saying that
because it's true no one's really
looking for love on amazing it's a crazy
it does happen I always say like no what
this is a terrible place to go to
actually find love but because it's a
reality show but people do really fall
in love
is that watched with my own but the
thing about is that you know every time
you watch a reality dating show you kind
of go that gu not here for the right
reasons like don't pick him girl but on
our show these guys have admitted that
they're not here for the right reasons
so there'll be a clip of them being like
I have to go on this date today and I
don't even like her I'm going to have to
pretend the whole time I'm just here for
the money and some of these guys the
good news is that some of these guys
that came there for the money they the
reason that they are scoundrel guys is
because they're able to be they can be
on their phones all the time they can go
women they don't have to like stay in a
relationship but on this island we forc
them to like go on dates multiple times
so they for the first time in their
lives they have intimacy and they start
to like like these women and kind of go
what have I been doing my whole life
like I have feelings for the first time
and they kind of like ditch their F boy
ways and it's so we have both of it
where they're like they're truly the
worst people in the world and then we
have guys that kind of change their ways
it is C interesting for me you start
with these people you walk in and then
all of a sudden you leave the season and
it's like how different people have
changed or or you were like no that one
was a tool oh totally yes exactly
but it's fun to play along and guess
like who is who it's just a great show
and it's a comedy show too I love that
it's so fun so fun all right we need a
commercial break everybody F boy Island
airs Mondays on the CW we're going to be
right
[Music]
[Applause]
back thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
oh